what's going on everybody it's Warren
and marvel hit us with a huge surprise
this morning dropping the second
Avengers endgame full official trailer
this morning and it was amazing we got
so much in this trailer so much more
than I ever thought we would get in an
Avengers in game trailer including Tony
Stark's being back on earth and the
Avengers in their white quantum realm
suits there's so much to talk about I've
watched it so many times already so
let's jump in to the trailer breakdown
real quick reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Avengers in
game and IMAX if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so the trailer starts off with
the one and only Tony Stark still
stranded in space sending his message to
pepper the reason I think he's still in
space is because he says I was really
hoping to pull off one last surprise
implying that he didn't pull it off he
didn't defeat Thanos and now he's stuck
in space he's not going to come home and
as he's talking and as we hear other
people talking we see flashbacks to
previous Marvel movies flashbacks to the
very first movies that we got for the
original Avengers Tony Stark's stuck in
the desert with a Mach 1 Iron Man suit
Captain America looking at himself in a
reflection seeing himself as a soldier
before he got the super serum and then
we have a bit of new footage with
Hawkeye training his daughter to shoot a
bow and arrow clearly in the past
because in the very next scene we see
him in Japan as Ronin we see Natasha
find him and the two of them hold hands
this obviously means that his family's
no longer here they were victims of the
snap which is something that we
predicted even before the trailer came
out we realized there had to be
something that made him become Ronin and
it was the death of his family so that's
just further full confirmation of that
in this trailer we see more flashbacks
flashbacks to Captain America where he's
actually holding the casket of Peggy
Carter when she died
flashbacks to Thor speaking with Odin
seen Asgard before it was destroyed in
thor ragnarok and then it focuses on
Thor and starts to show people turn into
dust
says I saw all these people die probably
filling some guilt for not going forth a
noses head and hitting him in the chest
to a Stormbreaker it then focuses on
captain america and he says i keep
telling everybody that they should move
on some do but not us
and in the scene we see black widow back
with her red hair there is still a
little bit of blonde at the tips but she
has her red hair again and we see bruce
banner as well they're clearly at the
avengers headquarters and then we see
ant-man and it looks like he just got
out of the quantum realm because he's
looking at a pole that has a bunch of
missing persons posters on it and he
looks really confused like he got out of
the quantum realm went home that he knew
then he sees these posters everywhere
and this is most likely when he realizes
that something big has happened he's out
of the quantum realm he can't find hank
janitor hope he can't find his daughter
so he realized that something is up and
he heads to the avengers headquarters we
then get a whole bunch of new footage
and on top of it we hear Natasha say
even if there's a small chance we owe it
to everybody who's not in this room to
try talking about the Avengers who are
no longer with them obviously about the
world but I think specifically right
here
The Avengers that aren't there to fight
back we see Black Widow and Hawkeye
talking and again we see her with red
hair and we see Hawkeye running away
from an explosion and then we get this
awesome scene right here with rocket on
war machines back this could be at the
Avengers headquarters we've seen some
leaks that made us to believe that
Thanos with his army is going to come
and attack the Avengers headquarters
this could be some of what we're seeing
right here also an even better shot of
rocket in his original guardians of the
galaxy suit from the comics and then we
get a ton more new footage and we hear
Captain America say we will whatever it
takes
and obviously this audio can be cut and
it might not be a direct reply to
Natasha but what we're supposed to think
here is that they will undo the snap
they're going to do whatever it takes to
undo what Thanos has done and Natasha
replies back whatever it takes this is
probably from the same conversation that
Natasha and Steve are having from the
very first Avengers trailer that we got
where Natasha says this is going to work
Steve and he says I know it is because I
don't know what I'm going to do if it
doesn't I think when the movie finally
comes out this will be one converse
we also see nebula screaming in what
looks like just complete destruction in
the background it's hard to tell what
this could be it could be a lot of
things I've heard some people say that
it's still on Titan I don't think it's
on Titan still it could be that attack
on the Avengers headquarters and nebula
sees Thanos which is why she's screaming
and then we see Hawkeye and it almost
seems like he's wearing his white
quantum realm suit but if you take a
look at his left hand you can see a
white light glowing this could be that
circular device that we've seen on all
the leaked photos so he could actively
be using whatever this devices be a time
travel or being in the quantum realm in
this scene right here if you noticed
there are red lights in the background I
think this is the red that we saw in the
scene with Hawkeye from the Avengers
in-game Superbowl TV spot there was a
lot of speculation of what that red
could be whether it was the reality
stone or Ultron but we can clearly see
here that it's just red lights in a
hallway and in the previous scene in
this trailer we see him running through
a hallway that looks very similar to
this from an explosion
so that scene from the TV spot for the
Super Bowl could simply be after the
explosion and some of these red lights
are still on then we see this amazing
clip of Captain America strapping his
shield on has the shield again has the
helmet back on and it looks like he's in
the middle of a huge battle the
background looks to be the same as the
one that nebula is in so again this
could be an attack on the avengers
headquarters fan OHS himself or somebody
in his army could have followed Tony
Stark and nebula back to earth to the
Avengers headquarters and then attacked
so that could be what we're seeing in
the background a destroyed Avengers
headquarters and the next scene with
ant-man kind of further leads me to
believe that that is the case because we
see him jumping on a pencil we also see
a pin in the background which obviously
means that it's in some sort of setting
to where there could be a pencil and a
pin there which leads me to believe that
it could be an office from the Avengers
headquarters and then we hear Tony Stark
say whatever it takes and then BAM we
see all of the Avengers who are left
together walking in the avengers
headquarters and they're white suits so
if you did not believe those suits were
real they are 100% real and look who's
walking with the Avengers on earth at
the Avengers headquarters in the white
suit himself Tony Stark so
clearly he makes it back to earth you
can see nebula walking with the white
suit on as well clearly not a huge
surprise I think everybody thought that
he was going to make it back but did not
think we were going to see it in the
trailer but there he is with the white
suit on we then roll the Avengers logo
and then the final scene is between Thor
and Captain Marvel so there was actually
a leak for the scene last week in which
it described exactly what we see right
here so if you caught my video on the
leaked description from that Disney
shareholders meeting that is 100%
confirmed real so what we learned from
that scene is that the Avengers are
actually going to look for fan OHS they
actually know where he is nebula says
that when Thanos was perfecting her he
would tell her where he was going to
retire when it was all said and done and
that she knows where he is and rocket
also says that when Thanos snapped there
was a huge surge of energy and he can
still detect that energy on a distant
planet and that's where Thanos is I'll
link that full video in the link above
so you can check it out yourself to
check out this scene and I have to say
I'm here for Thor and Captain Marvel I
totally ship them I think it's going to
be awesome to see these two together on
screen two insanely powerful characters
that I really want to see fight
side-by-side so that was my official
Avengers in-game trailer to breakdown I
love Marvel I love the Russo brothers
dropping the trailer on us without any
warning whatsoever and it was amazing it
was way more than I thought we'd ever
get from an Avengers end game trailer so
let me know your thoughts on this I want
to know what your favorite part of this
trailer was let me know what you think
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe like the video
comment on the video let me know what
you thought about this let me know what
your favorite scene was also so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Marvel and
Avengers in game I truly appreciate
everybody watching thank you so much as
always woof-woof
[Music]
you